Ukrainian military officials say the capital city
of chieve is under attack this morning Air Raid
Sirens wailed across the city today after Russia
launched several missiles targeting critical
infrastructure no word yet on any casualties or
the extent of the damage it is the first time
Russia has attacked the capital since New Year's
Day Russia's military has been focused on Fierce
fighting in the East after the Kremlin claim
control of the salt mine town of solidar but
Ukraine has denied the Takeover and claims it's
just part of Russian President Putin's propaganda
machine Deborah patter reports from Kiev it's
one of the bloodiest battles since the War Began
Russia claims it's taken control of solidar
Ukraine disputes this its forces have been
holding out against a ferocious Russian Onslaught
led by Wagner Mercenaries the fight for the small
salt mining town in eastern Ukraine has assumed
an outsized significance but a win in solidar
would give Vladimir Putin his first Victory
after months of humiliating losses this man
was instrumental evgeny pregosian the leader of
the Russian mercenary group Wagner volunteer in a
Russian prison recruiting convicts to fight on
the front line in solidar and Bahamut in this
video pregozian congratulates the first batch of
returning Fighters you've finished your contract
with honor he said Don't drink don't use drugs or
rape women Ukrainian military analyst Alexander
kovalenko says arming hardened criminals has
created the risk of even more Battlefield
atrocities with those convicts can commit any
crime he thinks necessary to win the battle he
said all he's done is build a blood business
already he told us they've seen an increase in
war crimes in the areas where Wagner is fighting
has been outspoken in his criticism of senior
Russian military leaders and their Battlefield
losses including Putin's newly appointed general
in charge of the war Valerie garasimov for
CBS Saturday morning Deborah patter Keith